- I love your writing. I love everything.
So, do you remember the very
first song you ever wrote?
- I do.
- I do too.
What was yours called?
- Mine's called, Lucky Me.
- Lucky Me?
- Yeah, what was yours?
- Baby Blue Eyes.
- [guest star] Ooh, I
see, I like that hook.
- It was about a boy.
- Yeah, mine was too, mine was too.
I wrote mine at a Sleepover,
nine years old,
and she went to one room,
and I went to the other, and we were like,
let's write a song and come back,
and share it with each other.
- What a cool nine year
olds you are right?
- [guest star] I know right?
- Mine was later than that.
What?
- [guest star] I know.
And then,
- Was her song crap, and
yours was really good?
(laughter)
- I mean.
One ended up being a songwriter,
(laughter)
and one didn't.
(clapping)
(laughter)
- I love that,
at nine though.
That's amazing.
- At nine years old.
- Lucky me.
- Do you remember what it sounds like?
- Oh, I do. And it ain't real good,
but I'm a sing it for you.
- Okay. I want, I want a tiny bit.
Just a tiny bit.
- Okay.
(clears throat)
♪ Lucky me ♪
♪ I feel free ♪
♪ And I, can't deny that he loves me ♪
♪ Which I know, that he does ♪
♪ So he is the one ♪
♪ Lucky Me ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ I said, oh ♪
♪ I'm the one for him ♪
♪ And a he's the one for me, baby ♪
That's all I'm a perform.
- Nine years old?
- No more, no more, no more
- I know, right?
- I know, I was like, I
haven't been (inaudible).
- She was like, she, look,
she was wagging her finger.
- (inaudible) baby
(laughter)
- She was like, you don't know
it but I'm the, (laughter)
I love that,
that you're writing that
at like, nine years old.